[Music]
our opinion is
uh you know that this didn't impact the
game um we had a good team
um
we won the world series and we'll leave
it at that did you say you feel like
this didn't impact the game
what do you mean by that i didn't say it
didn't impact the game um we're
apologizing because we broke the rules
but isn't science stealing a distinct
advantage for the hitter so doesn't it
automatically impact competition
it it it could possibly do that it could
possibly not
okay guys we're gonna wrap up thank you
dusty thank you jim
okay uh okay our owners are about to
talk himself into a corner here and not
give them any way out we need to end
this press conference
he's already in the corner they should
they should have gotten the big hook
remember the big hook they used to use
yeah they should have had the big hook
for that guy right like a long time ago
uh or they should have been doing this
isn't this what they do when it's time
to go to the
relievers um that's all i know about
baseball is this is that did i steal
that sign from somewhere i don't know uh
look here here's here's the thing here's
the thing
and i'm judging this from afar it's
obvious to me
that
baseball realizes what the astros did
was horrendous and that
it did undermine their 2017 world series
title and it should be taken away but
they're trying to thread this needle in
a way
that makes it look like they're taking
it seriously but for whatever reason
they're not giving them the punishment
they deserve the mlb commissioner over
the weekend saying that it would have
been futile to take away a piece of
metal like that's all the world series
trophy
simple uh
signifies yeah if i signify signify
signify uh
and it's it's it's ludicrous to me take
away the trophy it's tainted it's all
tainted they they want to acknowledge it
a little bit fire a few people issue
some punishment and then let's all move
on can't we just move on peop that's
what people say when they don't want to
talk about anymore can't we just move on
yeah because they don't know what else
to say because when they try to talk
about it they get twisted nuts like jim
crane did anyway we mention all that not
because all of a sudden we have an
interest in baseball because i
definitely don't here's what i have an
interest in you got guys in that locker
room you got guys in that clubhouse you
got cheaters there chris right
how would you have handled a teammate
how would you have accepted or not i
wouldn't have who was who was blatantly
admitted and involved in a cheating
scandal like this i mean i would have
tried i really would have tried to make
a thing of it in the locker room that's
what i would have been i would i would
have started to call people out and just
go like listen you guys are crazy this
is eventually going to get out and we're
all going to be you know thrown under
the bus and legacies are going to be
ruined all that anybody that's listened
to me on my podcast through the years
whether it was here at nbc or bleacher
report prior to this they would know
from my history that i am so
anti-cheating i give up on you forever
and what the astros did was total bs
bs and i love baseball i'm a huge
baseball fan you know i'm a yankees fan
and all of that they should have been in
the world series that year well yeah
well they should have been that was what
altuve holding his uh jersey so we
didn't see his buzzer i mean it's just
fishy yeah you know again baseball he
had a bad tattoo oh that's another one
okay join the club i got one too i don't
run around the bases like that all right
i mean geez they just it just you know
hey listen stein's sign stealing's been
around for a long time i understand that
but not when we use technology and start
using like weird banging on the trash
can or buzzards on the chest or using a
camera and then having a tv that's there
in the dugout so the players can see and
everything like that that's going too
far that is just blatant cheating that's
wrong and i guess i'm bothered by it i'm
bothered by that i'm bothered by some
people in baseball who like are mad that
people in the astros locker room let
this out because it's an unwritten rule
you know baseball you have to stop with
all your bull crap unwritten rules i
love you baseball but like nobody told
about the steroids nobody talks about
cheating like your unwritten rules are
ruining your sport stop
wouldn't it be funny if jose altuve's
tattoo was actually kyle shanahan's
initial you're fine
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports